hate the Democrats sick of Republicans
well then try the Libertarian Party
founded in 1971 the Libertarian Party is
perfect for those fiscally conservative
yet socially liberal folks who say hey
government leave us the heck alone
with taxes cut them drugs legalize them
overseas worse no thank you free-trade
yes please goes let us have them
abortions what wouldn't have them
transgender bathroom laws odd cheese put
it to rest already libertarians say they
value personal liberty above anything
else and boy do they mean it gay married
couples ought to be able to protect
their marijuana fields with fully
automatic machine guns groovy they've
never gotten more than one percent of
the popular vote but this year
libertarians may have a shot to turn
things around donations to the
libertarian party are skyrocketing and
some Republicans are switching parties
to get the heck away from the GOP thanks
to this Joker so if you want to cut
welfare for the poor but also would like
to smoke weed wherever you want consider
libertarianism because no one tells you
what to do